dans le bâtiment également
et on dirait qu'ils sont doués pour la
façonnerie
que les Français
donc Clermont-Ferrand capitale de
l'Auvergne vivent plus de 150 000
habitants
à l'intérieur de cette capitale une
autre capitale celle du pneu
elle emploie sur place plus de 25000
personnes en faisant ainsi vivre plus de
80 000
[Musique]
si en effectif total qui tourne
aujourd'hui vers 28000 nous avons 7 à
8000 employés ou ingénieurs et cadre en
ce qui concerne le personnel ouvrier les
nécessités de la production nous ont
amené à recruter un nombre important de
personnels immigrés principalement
ibérique disons même portugais
actuellement madame vous êtes portugaise
depuis combien de temps êtes-vous
installé ici
et cette maison c'est vous qui l'avez
remise en état c'est mon mari oui c'est
un gros travail
il est certain que l'arrivée de la
population étrangère a apporté des
améliorations dans notre petit village
auvergnat petit village que de vignerons
ou depuis la fin du siècle dernier au
début de ce siècle là de nombreuses
maisons avaient été abandonnées par les
vignerons d'ailleurs qu'il y avait
quitté le pays
nous sommes ici dans un quartier
précisément ou le nombre de maisons en
ruine était très grandes et ces maisons
étaient presque toutes reprises par de
la population étrangère notamment par la
population portugaise c'est donc bien
fait pour nous qu'ils soient venus et
qu'ils aient pu restaurer toutes ces
maisons
ils ont fait du travail un travail de
Romain veut-on dire parce qu'on les a vu
pendant des vieilles pierres qui ont
taillées quittaient ça
des ruines en état et Dieu merci les
ruines il y avait pas mal ici et à
Gergovie aussi
et travailler le soir
dans le bâtiment également
et on dirait qu'ils sont doués pour la
maçonnerie
que les Français
livré entièrement ce qu'on peut en
profiter
ils sont très tard
est-ce qu'il y a des points de friction
avec la population française quelquefois
entre jeunesse principale
rivalité amoureuse
sportive
entre enfants se fait assez normalement
néanmoins il est assez intéressant de
noter que dans leur jeu laisser trancher
ont souvent apporté le disons de la
parole leurs geste et il est
symptomatique quand même de voir surtout
les matchs de entre élèves les matchs de
football
ou dans nos cours les enfants font leur
soi-disant équipe de France et qui joue
contre les Portugais et symptomatique
aussi de voir que dans l'équipe de
France les petits Français prennent des
Espagnols et des italiens mais ne
prennent jamais de portugais que
représente pour un commerçant la
présence d'une colonie portugaise si
forte de toute façon pour moi c'est ma
plus grosse cliente et voyez la
clientèle portugaise ici
c'est si vous n'avez pas les Portugais
franchement
ça n'irait pas du tout quoi
autre chose intéressante c'est que ils
sont apportés beaucoup de main d'oeuvre
sur le plan disons régional mais aussi
sur le plan local cette année nous avons
beaucoup d'entre eux pour y ramasser le
raisin
avant notre entouré des terrains
la plus et c'est grâce à eux quand même
si certains exécuteur on peut ramasser
leur récolte en peu de temps
et les femmes travaillent aussi dans les
champs travaillent aussi elles ont tous
ils ont tous un jardin
et les femmes ont fait des ménages les
particuliers
à 10 km de Clermont-Ferrand ce village
s'appelle La Roche Blanche
il compte 1900 habitants
bien sûr de la scolarisation de les
problèmes ont été assez importantes
surtout à partir de
1963 1964 ou une arrivée massive dans un
étranger scolarisable surtout des
enfants en portugais nous a posé de
graves problèmes parce qu'il a fallu
ouvrir un très rapidement deux classes
supplémentaires et des bâtiments
préfabriqués et de toute façon le
problème des étrangers atteint ainsi un
point crucial parce que il est estimé
que lorsqu'on atteint 10 à 20% de
l'effectif total c'est déjà très lourd
nous sommes arrivés à 1967 68 à 67%
d'enfants d'origine étrangère dans nos
classes donc un retard du moins
ralentissement dans le travail et nous
sommes été amenés à ouvrir une place qui
accueille les enfants venant directement
du pays d'origine mais ne connaissant
pas la langue française vous vous êtes
le
j'en ai un qui parle pas beaucoup ça
ressemble un peu à votre village de
Portugal oui ça ressemble un peu mais
chez nous il y a beaucoup plus d'arbres
qui s'y voyez
et vous trouvez tout ce qu'il faut pour
faire la cuisine portugaise
la morue aussi ah oui
de la morue sèche
par jour vous voyez au moins au moins en
moyenne oui beaucoup d'huile de pâte de
riz
mais enfin quand même de plus en plus
elle vienne aux produits
si vous voulez
un exemple yaourt
il fallait pas leur en parler parce que
c'était
[Musique]